in 1993 Chipotle is founded by this guy
Steve ELLs after graduating culinary
school in 1990 ELLs works as a sous-chef
in San Francisco and becomes enamored
with local mission style burritos known
for their jumbo size and tin foil
wrappers three years later
eles borrows about 75 K from his dad and
uses the loan to open the first Chipotle
Mexican Grill in Denver
eles calculates he has to sell 114
burritos a day to break even by the end
of the first month Chipotle Mexican
Grill is selling over a thousand
burritos a day ello starts expanding and
in 1996 his parents raised about 1.3
million dollars mostly from wealthy
friends but to grow quickly
Chipotle needs a lot more capital enter
McDonald's in the late 90s Mickey D's
wants to prove to its investors its
diversified eventually it would go on to
buy Boston Market
Donatas pretti Mona protein Prettyman
and fizz oldies but first on their plate
is Steve else's burrito chain
in 1998 McDonald's invests about fifty
million dollars in Chipotle but over the
next three years
McDonald's grows to be Chipotle's
largest investor owning 90% of the brand
and investing around three hundred and
sixty million dollars by 2005 the food
with integrity brand has about five
hundred locations and is doing well but
there are conflicts with McDonald's over
the menu brand culture supply chain and
franchising so in 2006 the company's
part ways on January 26th Chipotle goes
public the IPO price is set at $22 by
the end of the first day it doubles to
$44 that growth is only the beginning
over the next seven years
Chipotle continues to expand and tries
its hand at Asian and Italian
restaurants but growing a company and
making ethically sourced delicious
burritos in always easy in July through
December 2015
ecoli Salmonella and norovirus and
Chipotle restaurants sickens people in
nine states since its IPO opens through
late 2015
Chipotle stock grows steadily but it
takes a major end after the bad
publicity Steve ELLs releases a
statement apologizing for the outbreaks
with a promise they are taking
aggressive steps to fix the problem On
February 8th 2016 Chipotle will close
all of its stores nationwide to hold a
staff meeting about food safety and best
practices Chipotle has been one of the
great success stories in the
fast-food industry the company hopes to
turn this controversy into a footnote
not in epitaph